do you think there's a lot of alien
civilizations out there
so i guess this also goes back to your
origin of life question too because i
think that that's key um
my personal opinion looking at all this
and and you know it's one of my hobbies
physics i guess so so i i you know it's
something i think about a lot and talk
to a lot of experts on and and and read
a lot of books on and i think
my feeling currently is that that we are
alone i think that's the most likely
scenario given what what evidence we
have so um and the reasoning is i think
that
you know we've tried
since uh things like seti program and i
guess since the dawning of the the space
age uh we've you know had telescopes
open radio telescopes and other things
and if you think about um and try to
detect signals now if you think about
the evolution of humans on earth we
could have easily been um a million
years ahead of our time now or million
years behind quite easily with just some
slightly different quirk thing happening
hundreds of thousands years ago uh you
know things could have been slightly
different if the bto had hit the
dinosaurs a million years earlier maybe
things would have evolved uh we'd be a
million years
ahead of where we are now so what that
means is if you imagine where humanity
will be in a few hundred years let alone
a million years especially if we
hopefully um
you know solve things like climate
change and other things and we continue
to flourish um and we build things like
ai and we do space traveling and all of
the stuff that that humans have dreamed
of for forever right and sci-fi has
talked about forever um
we will be spreading across the stars
right and void neumann famously
calculated you know it would only take
about a million years if you send out
von neumann probes to the nearest you
know the nearest uh other solar systems
and and then they built all they did was
build two more versions of themselves
and set those two out to the next
nearest systems uh you you know within a
million years i think you would have one
of these probes in every system in the
galaxy so it's not actually in cosmo
cosmological time that's actually a very
short amount of time
so and and you know we've people like
dyson have thought about constructing
dyson spheres around stars to collect
all the energy coming out of the star
you know that there would be
constructions like that would be visible
across base um probably even across a
galaxy so and then you know if you think
about all of our radio television uh
emissions that have gone out since since
the you know 30s and 40s um imagine a
million years of that and now hundreds
of civilizations doing that when we
opened our ears at the point we got
technologically sophisticated enough in
the space age we should have
heard a cacophony of voices we should
have joined that cacophony of voices and
what we did we open our ears and we
heard nothing
and many people who argue that there are
aliens would say well we haven't really
done exhaustive search yet and maybe
we're looking in the wrong bands and and
we've got the wrong devices and we
wouldn't notice what an alien form was
like to be so different to what we're
used to but you know i'm not i don't
really buy that that it shouldn't be as
difficult as that like we i think we've
searched enough there should be if it
were everywhere if it was it should be
everywhere we should see dyson's fears
being put up sun's blinking in and out
you know there should be a lot of
evidence for those things and then there
are other people argue well the sort of
safari view of like well we're a
primitive species still because we're
not space-faring yet and and and we're
you know there's some kind of globe like
universal rule not to interfere yeah
star trek rule but like look we can't
even coordinate humans to deal with
climate change and we're one species
what is the chance that of all of these
different human civilization you know
alien civilizations they would have the
same priorities and and and agree across
the you know these kind of matters and
even if that was true and we were in
some sort of safari for our own good to
me that's not much different from the
simulation hypothesis because what does
it mean the simulation hypothesis i
think in its most fundamental level it
means what we're seeing is not quite
reality right it's something there's
something more deeper underlying it may
be computational now if we were in a if
we were in a sort of safari park and
everything we were seeing was a hologram
and it was projected by the aliens or
whatever that to me is not much
different than thinking we're inside of
another universe because we still can't
see true reality right i mean there's
there's other explanations it could be
that
the way they're communicating is just
fundamentally different that we're too
dumb to understand the much better
methods of communication they have it
could be i mean i mean it's silly to say
but
our own thoughts could be the methods by
which they're communicating like the
place from which our ideas writers talk
about this like the muse
it sounds like very kind of uh
wild but it could be thoughts it could
be
some interactions with our mind that we
think are originating from
us is actually something that uh
is coming from other life forms
elsewhere consciousness itself might be
that it could be but i don't see any
sensible argument to them why why would
all of the alien species be seen this
way yes some of them will be more
primitive they will be close to our
level you know there would there should
be a whole sort of normal distribution
of these things right some would be
aggressive some would be you know
curious others would be very stoical and
philosophical because you know maybe
they're a million years older than us
but it's not it shouldn't be like what i
mean one one alien civilization might be
like that communicating thoughts and
others but i don't see why you know
potentially the hundreds there should be
would be uniform in this way right it
could be a violent dictatorship that the
the people the alien civilizations that
uh become successful
become um
[Music]
gain the ability to be destructive an
order of magnitude more destructive
um but of course the the sad thought
well
either humans are very special we took a
lot of leaps that arrived at what it
means to be human yeah
um
there's a question there which was the
hardest which was the most special but
also if others have reached this level
and maybe many others have reached this
level
the great filter yeah
that prevented them from going farther
to becoming a multi-planetary species or
reaching out into the stars
and those are really important questions
for us whether
um
whether there's other alien
civilizations out there or not this is
very useful for us to think about if we
destroy ourselves
how will we do it and how easy is it to
do yeah well you know these are big
questions and i've thought about these a
lot but the the interesting thing is
that if we're if we're alone
that's somewhat comforting from the
great filter perspective because it
probably means the great filters were
past us and i'm pretty sure they are so
that by in going back to your origin of
life question there are some incredible
things that no one knows how happened
like obviously the first life form from
chemical soup that seems pretty hard but
i would guess the multicellular i
wouldn't be that surprised if we saw
single
single cell sort of life forms elsewhere
uh bacteria type things but
multicellular life seems incredibly hard
that step of you know capturing
mitochondria and then sort of using that
as part of yourself you know when you've
just eaten it would you say that's the
biggest
the most uh like
if if you had to choose one sort of uh
hitchhiker's got this galaxy one
sentence summary of like oh those clever
creatures did this that would be the
multiples i think that was probably the
one that that's the biggest i mean
there's a great book called the 10 grand
in the great inventions of evolution by
nick lane and he speculates on 10 10 of
these you know what could be great
filters um i think that's one i think
the the advent of of of intelligence and
and conscious intelligence and in order
you know to us to be able to do science
and things like that is huge as well i
mean it's only evolved once as far as
you know uh in in earth history so that
would be a later candidate but there's
certainly for the early candidates i
think multicellular life forms is huge
you